we're unlucky enough if we meet with
people who want to do us wrong show us
contempt and take advantage of us
but this is as nothing next to the
monumental bad luck of encountering
people who do all this to us while also
being extremely skilled at pretending
that they aren't those master
manipulators who are at once innocent
seeming and deep down profoundly
scheming
these people won't only hurt us they
will do something far worse
rob us of our understanding of ourselves
strip us of basic trust and along the
way for a time
make us lose our minds
however good we might be at fighting
overt antagonists many of us are
constitutionally unprepared to detect
ones that have entered our intimate
lives we expect and can deal with
enemies at the office
but the bedroom feels like a sanctum
where our guard is down
yet this doesn't mean that some very
dark things can't unfold there
there are people we can take up with who
have been so badly hurt by something in
their early lives that they are
committed to exacting revenge on anyone
who comes too close to them
they may semi-consciously be seeking to
exercise on their partners a latent rage
against a dead or depressed parent they
may want to punish a bullying sibling or
release themselves from a sense of
intolerable vulnerability created by an
incident of early abuse such dark
possibilities are rarely spoken of in
useful terms there are plenty of popular
references to psychos and lunatics but
far fewer patient analyses of how
exactly other minds can be distorted and
how widespread longings for vengeance
may be beneath smiles and good manners
when we meet with difficulties we have
two explanations to fall back on the
first is to doubt ourselves the second
is to wonder whether and how the other
person might be ill
if we almost always pick the former it's
because of how familiar and reassuring
it is not to take our own sides
it is so much easier for us to think
that we are as they also quickly tell us
irrationally prone to anger overexcited
insane
and complaining for no reason rather
than deep in a relationship with a cruel
soul
those who are most prone to being gaslit
in adult love are sadly of course the
very people who may have been gaslit by
their own parents the idea sounds yet
more curious but parents too can be
adept at polishing their reputations and
will insist that they are kind while
simultaneously expending enormous
hostility on their thoroughly confused
child
despite decades of training in
self-doubt we may need to do a
remarkable thing trust in what our
unhappiness is telling us about those we
think of as good the test isn't whether
they tell us they love us it's how at
peace they make us feel
we may have to accept that the world is
filled with some very dangerous people
who look entirely safe to our fatefully
untrained eyes we may need to think a
bit less badly of ourselves and
substantially worse of some sweet
seeming characters who claim with great
sincerity to love us
and don't
the school of life offers online
psychotherapy to people all around the
world our therapists are highly trained
and accredited and are a vital source of
kindness solace and wisdom for life's
most difficult moments
click the link to find out more